[Music]
let's go girls yes our country Queen
Shania Twain is officially back with new
music dropping her latest single and
accompanying music video for the fiery
track giddy up
[Music]
shredding her stuff into 2023 the flirty
new song sets the stage for shania's
highly anticipated new album queen of me
dropping February 3rd the new project
marks her sixth full-length album and
first record since 2017. and yes I can
already picture myself dancing and
singing along to shania's latest hit
with her Global Queen Of Me Tour kicking
off in April
let's go girl the singer's upcoming tour
makes stops across North America and
Europe including 16 Canadian dates and
let's just say we are impressed
and to celebrate the song's release
Shania stopped by the Today Show looking
Pretty in Pink where she opened up about
the important meaning behind her new
album it means taking responsibility
ownership of yourself yeah you know
loving who you are it's a you know
I'm My Own royalty I'm the boss of me
and I'm responsible for the decisions I
make for what I say for what I do
and it's a statement of
self-confidence that I've grown into
more I Feel Like a Woman yes Shania
continues to be a strong role model for
women as she spoke about becoming even
more confident in herself as she ages
it's so essential more than ever because
as we age and you know our skin starts
to melt and all kinds of things happen
to us you know I I realized that wow I
was shy about
wearing a bikini at the beach when I was
younger and I'm thinking that was that
was ridiculous I gotta stop this
nonsense and start wearing a bikini to
the beach now we have
you know I just got to get over that
stuff
preach Shania at 57 years young the
singer continues to own her body and
discuss her decision to go topless on
the cover art for her single waking up
dreaming it was really scary but it was
sort of like you know I don't really
love my body I don't love looking at
myself in the mirror with the lights on
or looking in the mirror at all at my my
body
so I said listen I'm going to face that
fear I'm going to go into that photo
shoot and I'm going to put fashion aside
yeah so fashion we used to flatter our
shapes to to maybe hide the things we
don't like to make us look more like
what we wish we really did look like
without the clothes
putting fashion aside this is me it was
so empowering really I'm so glad I did
it I was petrified yeah yeah but once I
flicked that switch and dove into it I'm
like I'm all in I committed 100 percent